Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P here is a
Trumpist caller who is furious and is
warning me. My judgment day is coming.
Speaker 5: I seriously hope that people get
to sue you for calling them mentally ill.
Speaker 1: Well, that's their prerogative.
Speaker 5: 74 million people are mentally ill.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, I didn't say
74 million people are mentally ill.
We have talked with cult experts and mental health
experts. There are some Trumpists who are just
selfish people, but they are what we would call
sane. They saw Trump's policies as being good
for them personally, financially. That's one
group. There's another group of people who are
simply brainwashed. Those are more like the cult
people. They're not mentally ill in the sense we
normally mean. They're just brainwashed. There's
another group that's just ignorant. They've fallen
for lies that they don't know are lies. And then,
yes, there is a group that's mentally ill. We've
interviewed some of them at the rallies. But I've
never said 74 million people who voted for Trump
or mentally ill criticize me for things I've said.
Speaker 5: Please. What it is now. You know
what? When you stand before you go at the end of
judgment day. Yeah. You're going to be one. Sorry,
dude, I understand me wrong. The election was
stolen. Shooting crime, you name it. Well, in
that demon rat.
Speaker 1:
I guess he stays on the phone for a while.
I don't know if you can hear the static.
Sounds like a car drove by. Well, listen, when
I stand before and face judgment at the end,
maybe I will be sorry. We'll have to wait and
see if that happens. But the election was not
stolen. Donald Trump genuinely lost. That's
it. We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Republicans with unlimited sick days are voting
against time off for rail workers. We'll tell
you what's going on. A parents have refused
the use of vaccinated blood, the blood from
a vaccinated person for a life saving surgery for
their baby. Oh, boy. And an Iranian man was shot
dead for celebrating that Iran lost a World
Cup game to the United States. All of those
stories and many more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Sign up at join pacman
dot com. We will see you then.